very few people who write a book can get
roger federer and julia roberts to give
their two cents as to why you should buy
the book but bear grylls is not like
many people on planet earth his new book
never give up my life in the wild is
available where all books are sold bear
grylls here on the rich eisen show how
you doing sir
hey rach nice to be with you yeah thanks
for having me along you got it so um
let's get right into it how does one
become an adventurer in life how does
one get to
to be what you're doing
yeah that's interesting i think first of
all i think adventure it's a state of
mind actually you know i think it's in
it's in all of us isn't it uh
i think for me as a young young boy you
know it was the only thing i was ever
any good at is the honest answer you
know i wasn't a kind of brilliant
superstar and anything like that at
school uh but i love to go out and climb
with my with my late dad he'd been a
marine and loved all of that sort of
thing and i was brought up on a little
island off the south coast of england
and we're always kind of making little
rafts and climbing up the cliffs and
stuff and i think there's somebody that
said to me age seven that i could have a
job that involved
you know getting muddy and falling off
stuff i would have thought heaven so
you know i feel i look back now on a
lifetime of adventure i think it started
at a young age but um
really in those early days i just wanted
to be i think close to my dad you know
my way of doing that was we go and climb
and have these adventures together but
you know it's been it's been a great
privilege it's been a it's been a road
that i never really planned beyond that
beyond knowing that i wanted to
try and follow my heart try and follow
what i really loved what i was okay at
in life
and um
like i said i think i've been very lucky
i stand on the shoulders of many giants
is the truth
so is it true you came from a family of
uh cricketers like it's a a there's a
bunch of
history in your family of playing
cricket did you not go in that direction
anymore attempt to go in that direction
no they they were all much more they
were all much more talented than me yeah
i was a black sheep you know
um i couldn't do much apart from i as a
kid i was always a kid that could climb
the highest
building at school or the the highest
tree and you know where i lived and
stuff but um
which really when you're a kid isn't
much of a skill you know it it doesn't
hold a lot of currency when you're a kid
but um i loved it you know and
i've always tried my dad used to say to
me as a kid just uh
you know try and follow what you really
love and and be resilient and get
knocked back and keep smiling get back
up have a never give up spirit
and uh try and be kind to people along
the way and and that sort of thing meant
much more i think to my parents for me
growing up than just kind of
you know following the uh more
conventional past and i look back and
i'm so grateful for that in many ways
you know i'm a dad now to
three teenagers yeah and um and i think
you know as you know it's what we want
our children to be able to kind of
be resilient and to follow what they
love and and to try and be kind along
the way that really is life in a
nutshell i think so who's the first uh
bear grylls to come across you and say
we need to get you on television who's
the first person to say let's
let's put you over on mass media or
bring you to the people yeah well the
truth is i was a very reluctant person
to do that in the early days you know
and when i say about standing on the
shoulders of giants in my life i really
mean that you know from early days from
whether it was my dad teaching me to
climb or whether it was the person that
first gave me that break in tv but i
remember it so well you know i was just
leaving the military uh i'd um got back
from everest where we i'd written a book
on on a climb i did up there where we
had a whole bunch of things go wrong and
people lost their lives but eventually
two of us reached the top and i'd
written a book on that we just got mad i
just got married as well young starting
out in life
and uh
and a tv producer read the book and he
said well i know your
background with the military where my
job was teaching a lot of the combat
survival as part of the british special
forces
and he said well why don't we do a show
where we drop you in the middle of
nowhere and you show us how to get out
of there and i was like really kind of i
thought i don't know tv it wasn't my
thing i was kind of just leading the
expeditions and climbing and and giving
presentations on it and
scratching a few pennies here and there
and starting out you know right and um
but tv i said i'm not a tv presenter i
wouldn't know how to do that and i
remember i said no three times to them
and he kept saying this guy rob mciver
genius man still a still a friend
and uh he said we don't want a tv
presenter we just want you to do your
stuff we're going to follow and uh you
tell us what's going on and um
you know my wife who's smarter than me
she said uh
why don't you just try it you know why
don't you try it nothing to lose and we
went and we shot a pilot
and um we put they put it out late at
night with no marketing and the timing
was good and it just flew and that was
the first episode of man versus wild and
that opened the door to
everything else so i'm
standing on the shoulders of giants yes
so then when did you come up with the
idea of who came up with the idea let's
add a celebrity element to it let's put
you out
in the wall let's do running wild where
you're going to start having
uh a whole host of people from across
the sports or pop culture or political
landscape
how did you come across that one bear
grylls i love the idea well we did
successfully we did we did seven seasons
of man versus wild which is kind of one
lone man against the elements doing you
know with our great crew you know and i
think one of the things i'm most proud
of on our tv
kind of arsenal of shows is that we have
that same crew from the beginning still
best friends to this day i love that
very proud of that but i'm after seven
seasons
we um we got we got approached by our
first ever running wild guest which was
will ferrell and he said i love you just
to take me on an adventure we end up
filming it but it was part of man versus
wild it was kind of men versus wild i
think they called it and and again that
kind of flew and it was just at the time
where i was finishing with discovery
channel taking kind of step to nbc which
was my first network show
and um
and
we said why don't we just make a whole
series of this we call it running wild
i'll take along some other people we got
great guests you know quickly you know
we we in the next one was jake
gyllenhaal i think and you know i think
because we started really at the top
we've just always been really lucky and
just had amazing people and i always
think the wild as a real star of the
show you know it allows people to be
honest and to open up my job is to keep
them alive
keep it fun
not not kind of break people too much
and give them a great experience and
you know the the magic of running wild
really is is we bring new audiences
every time new fans new new guests new
stars and we're just kicking off season
eight now of running wild and
like i said it's been a true privilege
in my life uh something i never take for
granted it's a position of real trust
with these stars
but you should truly love it usually
here in los angeles um folks like your
guests
the the most they do is something called
glamping you know but that's pretty much
their version of wild is going glamorous
camping called glamping i'm sure you
might have heard of that but
what was will ferrell like in the wild
for your first
men versus
wow what was that well i think he would
have been he would have been dreaming of
some glamping yes i bet i didn't know
about that that's a great and it's a
genius great way of doing it but um will
ferrell definitely didn't get that that
version
um and actually i think one of the
errors we made in the early days of
running wild as we filmed for way too
long we got for days and days and we
were in the arctic in the wintertime
crazy low low temperatures and poor guy
was almost broken fired and still to
this day if i see him he would go oh my
god bear what that was the hardest thing
and um and we've kind of learned to you
don't need to go to such crazy extremes
temperatures anymore make it simple make
it shorter make it empowering and fun
but i think will had one of the hardest
ones we've ever done and it's a miracle
anyone ever signed up after it and it's
why i'm so grateful to those early shows
and the faith that those early stars put
in put in me before the show is
established really well for a colleague
of mine bear grylls for uh for quite a
while at nfl network was dion sanders
and i know he went up the wall with you
um what was prime like there did was he
well suited for the wild in any way
shape or form
bear prime time prime time was truly
unsuited to the wild
and i think he would say that by his own
admission yes i love that man and we had
we have so much fun and still to this
day you know i mean somebody sent me an
interview he did
recently where you know some people were
kind of ribbing him at about that trip
and you know
going prime you were amazing you were
brilliant but um but you were crazy and
he was and he suddenly gets very serious
he goes that was the worst i've ever
done in my life
and again i think you know we we push
him pretty hard maybe a little too hard
in retrospect but the problem with the
prime time one is that we were i took
him up this kind of mesa in utah and you
know blank wall thousand foot climb
you know poor guy
you know he gets pretty bad vertigo as
well but the problem is once you get
onto these wall climbs there's no out
you know and i think what i've learned
over many seasons of running wild is
you've always got to have an exit you've
always got to be able to adjust the
journey if people are really struggling
with something there was no adjusting or
or getting out of that one so we were on
this thing for hours and hours and hours
and but do you know what he never gave
up he has such a fun kind of
you know adventure spirit even though
he's none of those adventure skills or
experience he's got an adventure spirit
he laughed at himself he cried with
himself he was just brilliant and i i
love him and admire him so much for it
so he too me too he's one of my he's one
of my favorite people so um out of uh
the sports
stars that you have had uh in your midst
in your care
um drew brees shaquille o'neal roger
federer who again who wrote a very nice
accolade for you on the back of your new
book never give up my life in the wild
where all books are acquired which which
which one was well suited for the
adventurer lifestyle which one do you
think was well suited well i think um
drew brees is amazing isn't he you know
and such a cool cat calm under pressure
i think to be in that position that role
that he does you need to be calm under
pressure and actually that kind of
ability to think calm in the storm when
it's all happening fast is a key trait
of a survivor
he was he was amazing to take uh we were
in the jungle hard journey with him
uh a great friend we've got kept
attached and lovely family man and a
true hero and you know again somebody
really has that resilient spirit but
smart you know he's he leads with his
head which is the
so key to survival but um i love that
one the roger federer one was a
privilege for me because i'm a huge
tennis fan
loved that wanted to do a journey like
this with with roger for many years and
um
there did you did he actually sweat
because i've never seen that did he have
he didn't have his headband with him
i've never seen him break a sweat did he
break a sweat with you did that happen
no no i mean it didn't help the fact we
were minus 20 in the in in the snowy
mountains but um he got very cold i do
remember he got very cold i used to my
advantage because um
i thought all i want to do one time in
my life is i don't want to play tennis
with roger because it's just not gonna
you know
i'm not gonna be able to hold my own
there but ping pong table tennis i could
do you know so and i remember packing
this little uh i write about this but i
pat this little table tennis thing in
the backpack and take it up the mountain
and we eventually get to the top and
it's deep snow roger's going back and no
longer feel my hands a lot of shaking
and you know he's looking for help i'm
looking this is my time for the match
you know i'm witnessing out here we go
ready to go and he goes what now and i
go now verse 11 this is it he's going
okay
and then i go straight in he goes no
warm-up i go you've got to be kidding
with three love up um here we go
but um i remember i remember i think we
got like nine all and he started to get
his he started to get his eye and hand
in his blood came back and then he
there was only ever going to be one
winner he beat me 11 9 then but uh what
what a fun guy and
i remember we put that one on the show
to kind of wimbledon graphics with all
the scoreboards
he gave a commentary on it afterwards
but
you know what a cool guy what a cool cat
he didn't sweat great heart true family
man and you know again with so many of
these guests on running wild you get to
know the real person you know it's not
like a sort of three minutes on a chat
show where you know almost becomes you
know as you know where your podcast is
lovely and different and more in depth
but i think on the tv stuff it becomes a
performance often for people and you
know running was great like your podcast
you have time to get to know someone and
it's it's slower and that's um that's
the magic i think
so uh before i let you go why the book
why now what what uh what led you to
want to add this to everything else that
you've done and written about in your
life
well it's so many of the stories i get
asked about all day by so many people
you know behind the scenes on man versus
what was it really like what's the worst
you've ever eaten the closest you've
come to dying what's it really like
running wild with obama whilst he's in
office or with prime minister modi of
india and so many stories and i think
for my kids i really wanted them to know
those i also wanted them to know
the struggles behind the
the things that you know i think our
families grow up and see the good stuff
they see the successes but for me my
book was only ever going to be called
one thing which was never give up
because it's been that
through the door so many failures you
know and that really is the truth i
think behind all the things that have
worked out they've been a hundred
disasters and you've got to get back on
your feet and be resilient and i think
it's
one of the most important messages for
all of us to share at this time when so
many young people facing battles and
struggles is that do you know what
i've never met a strong person who's had
an easy past you know that past the
struggles the battles are what really
make us and i wanted to share those with
with people who kind of like myself but
also for me with my kids especially so
i'm proud of it i've written every word
i'm grateful for you for kind of you
know sharing it but um i hope people
enjoy it well i'm i'm grateful for you
coming on i literally could ask all
those questions of you but people will
just have to read it in the book
and uh i appreciate the time right here
i'd i'd love to meet you in person one
day but uh that's the extent of it um
i'm not really uh much of an adventurer
i like sitting on a set
uh climate controlled um craft services
you know that's the sort of type of uh
broadcast i'm used to
but maybe you know just maybe if there
is a slot you know i'll i'll i'll join
you at some point in time i love that i
love it i'm i'm in and uh
you could argue that you're smarter than
me that's all that's the difference
you know what and i i've looked and
followed your stuff for a long time and
i would say you definitely have an
adventure spirit state of mind as we
said at the beginning i appreciate that
thanks thanks so much for the time here
bear uh bear grylls never give up my
life in the wild where all books are
acquired right here on the rich eisens
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here